calling for safe harbor the Spanish
rescue vessel open arms remains off the
coast of Italy carrying more than 120
migrants had picked up from the
Mediterranean Sea Italy's refusing to
let it dark and as threatening a fifty
thousand dollar fine if the captain
tries but since the Italian parliament
approved a new law on Monday targeting
aid ships open arms could face a fine of
up to one point 1 million dollars there
were protests against the so-called
security decree which allows for the
arrest of captains who ignore orders to
stay out of Italian ports and the
immediate seizure of their boats the
European Union says it's analyzing the
changes to see if they're compatible
with EU laws while the UN's refugee
agency warns the decree could put
already vulnerable people in even more
danger NGOs play an invaluable role in
saving the lives of refugees and
migrants attempting the dangerous sea
crossing to Europe their commitment and
humanity should not be criminalized nor
stigmatized the decree is seen as a
victory for Deputy Prime Minister Matteo
salvini and his far-right league party
he says rescued migrants can only land
in Italy if an agreement is already in
place with other European countries to
look after them
[Applause]
in June the German captain of a sea
watch rescue ship was briefly detained
for breaking an Italian naval blockade
trying to stop her bringing a group of
migrants ashore it's at least one of the
main Mediterranean entry points for
people fleeing conflict and poverty in
the Middle East and North Africa the UN
says nearly 4,000 have landed in Italy
so far this year after the treacherous
crossing the EU has been funding the
Libyan Coast Guard to help them turn
around migrant boats but the bombings of
a migrant detention center in Libya last
month raised global concern open-armed
says the people it's rescuing tells
stories of rape and other violence in
Libya for now they remain stuck at sea
Alexei O'Brien al Jazeera